working less for a living maybe we told
you last week about how a pilot program
in the UK testing a four day work week
was so successful that nine out of 10
companies involved said they would make
it permanent so it raises an obvious
question here in these United States
could it work here Scott McFarland
reports now on the growing interest in
state legislatures and even Congress to
give employers the chance to find out
one fewer day each week of the alarm
clock and the morning commute John Burns
says once his software company in
Baltimore instituted a 32-hour work week
the productivity of his 37 employees
increased so did profits we've asked the
employees to ruthlessly look at their
work
get rid of extraneous meetings
extraneous phone calls paperwork
um things of this nature and reduce down
the amount of wasted work the kovid
stay-at-home orders gave millions of
workers their first taste of flexible
work arrangements and some employers
discovered less can be more are you
drawing people like you and me or are
you drawing younger employees definitely
younger employees we've had a lot of um
folks coming right out of college that
are like this is where we want to work a
CBS News Review finds at least a half
dozen states to varying degrees are now
considering legislation to make four-day
work weeks more common
including Maryland where new legislation
would offer companies that Institute
shorter work weeks a tax break Maryland
delegate Von Stewart is one of the
Bill's sponsors we're expecting that
workers can be at least as productive in
a 32-hour week as they are in a 40-hour
week it's a pretty provocative argument
sure but we're but we're thinking that
with more hours of rest
workers are going to be able to function
better employees in four day a week
Studies have reported less stress and
less burnout and better physical health
but Advocates like Boston college
professor Juliet Shore say the idea
might require prodding from government
historically work time reduction has
always involved government we put in or
at least you know in the last 200 years
or so we we put in
um a 40-hour week in the United States
in the 1930s new legislation in New York
California in the U.S Congress would
require companies that work employees
more than 32 hours a week to pay
overtime
similar proposals have failed in the
past California's Chamber of Commerce
called it a job killer not suited for
all employers even supporters of the
four-day Work Week acknowledge it's not
for everyone absolutely we don't think
this is something that every single
industry and every single business can
do but that's what we want to study
I think it's important to note Nate this
might not apply to people in television
but the supporters of that Maryland Bill
say they want it to be a range of
employees impacted White Collar blue
collar to reflect a broad spectrum of
employees but Nate we got to cut you
back from the seven day week you're
working right now
well Scott you work just as much as me
but you know what we love working seven
days a week here at CBS right Scott no
it's no other reason we get to see Gail
more yes that's is true speaking of girl
how do you feel about it I don't know
anybody that wants to work seven days
but when you look at the benefits of the
four day week I don't see why more
people wouldn't do it okay but parents
with young children are like does it
mean I have to take care of my
two-year-old and four-year-old another
day of the week no I mean that I don't
want it then I want them in school or I
want I want the sitter work in five days
true no doubt about it we'll see though
we'll see what happens state to state